à manger par petit dégénéré à j'attends
le patron on attend le patron il arrive
une d'hillary vers 10 heures il me dit
ah vous êtes là c'est vous les candidats
ajouté je dis ok j'ai une réunion je
reviens voire plus tard donc on attend
on attend on attend d'entendre à 17
heures et l'arrivée des hommes est mince
je vous ai oublié ce que vous allez
faire revenez demain s'il vous plaît
ok y'a pas de soucis je reviens le
lendemain
le lendemain du revers à 7 heures
voilà ton attendu patron on l'attend on
l'attend au late ans l'attend l'attend
au latin l'attend
à 17h revient il jouait encore désolé
mais vraiment j'ai beaucoup de travail à
l'heure actuelle
mais revenez demain
le lendemain quand on revient on était
plus une dizaine le surlendemain on
était quatre personnes
donc là on attend on attend on attend on
attend il vient vers 15h 16h et puis
regarde on est plus que trois
venez dans mon bureau vous n'êtes que
trois jeux vidéo qu'est considéré que
vous avez le boulot laissez moi vos cv
et regarde et me dit vous ne vous
commencez le lendemain et comme ça mon
aventure de professionnels venait de
démarrer je commence maintenant j'ai un
boulot je suis fier on me montre un
secteur on me dit va prendre ce secteur
il te fois sans boutique il faut livrer
tous les jours donc je livre et à la fin
du mois mon premier salaire on m'a payé
50 mille francs cfa à l'époque ça fait
l'équivalent de 80 euros peut-être je
pense ça doit être ça
et donc
je suis très fier de moi
mais pas plus fier que quand j'arrive je
trouve un podium je dis qu'est ce qui se
passe on me dit ici il ya les meilleurs
qui sont là chaque année on les
récompense
et qu'est ce qu'on leur donne non
seulement leur donne un trophée mais on
leur donne un chèque
faut que je sois là bas l'année de
l'année prochaine
pour que ce soit sur ce podium l'année
prochaine
vous imaginer quoi l'année qui a suivi
on a sorti les noms il y avait abdou
arabe benjelloun et bien écrit
et là
on me dit voilà maintenant tu fais
partie des meilleurs donc tu aura
certainement une promotion donc on a
besoin d'un analyste on a vu ton profil
mais il ya un problème sur ton profil
papa ton diplôme universitaire
universitaire là on ne voit pratiquement
après le bac qu'est ce que tu as fait
j'ai dit oui je suis allé à l'université
m'a l'université atépa en fait je suis
arrivé moi je n'aime que l'informatique
et les consoles moi c'est ce que je me
touche à l'ordinateur c'est ce que je
voulais je suis allé j'ai fait le cours
d'informatique je suis sorti premier du
cours en informatique
les stats ça va les autres mais bon
l'année qui a suivi on voulait trop me
mettre dans des histoires de calculs
statistiques et autres là franchement ça
m'a pas intéressé
ok mais tu sais touché à l'ordinateur je
dis oui on met en rapport avec les les
ingénieurs à l'époque et puis je me mets
à
m'apprennent comment fonctionne une
usine je travaille pourquoi guette
palmolive c'est le savons donc chaque
matin il va falloir calculé l'état des
stocks qui va falloir savoir combien de
matières premières en a besoin parce que
les les usines c'est pas comme les
entreprises commerciales ou les
entreprises qui viennent juste avant de
peut-être un produit la pâte dentifrice
lusine c'est vous avez de la matière
première jusqu'à la production donc il
faut stocker les matières premières faut
stocker les produits intermédiaires il
faut stocker aussi les produits finis
et il faut pas tomber en rupture parce
qu'on était en position vraiment numéro
un donc le savon traditionnel que vous
voyez
fabriquons donc si ça ça manque qu au
sénégal dit vous qu'aucun sénégalais ne
va prendre la douche entre la journée
donc comme ça je continue à travailler
et puis un jour on me dit donc voilà
donc qu'il ya un poste d'analyste qui
est là qui peut être là pour toi
on en discute je dis bon je serai donc
capable de le faire donc on me dit en
même temps que les autres tu seras un
stage mais bon si tu as choisi un jour
on va t'appeler
comme je continue mon stage
tranquillement donc je vais le stage
prendra un mois à la fin du stage donc
je dois revenir sur mon terrain j'avais
bien sur mon terrain et puis là soir
il n'ya pas mon patron pas celui qui
m'avait reçu quand je devais faire mon
interview mais
pas son patron à lui mais son patron au
dessus de lui c était juste en dessous
du dg c'est le direct dans la plaie
directeur général des ventes donc vous
imaginez que quand je reçois l'appel de
ce monsieur par lui directement mais sa
secrétaire qui médit il ya monsieur
abdou qui veut vous voir le lendemain
c'est j'ai passé une nuit de folie
je suis resté avec ma femme on n'a pas
pu dormir tous les jours j'étais déjà
stressés judy mais attend le monsieur il
m'appelle par mon petit il peut changer
ma vie demain
qu'est ce qui va se passer et le
lendemain j'arrive je le trouve dans son
bureau je discute avec lui tout s'est
bien passé il me serre la main il
m'accompagne et puis mais dit aussi je
vous choisi vous allez recevoir madame x
va vous appeler jeudi d'accord
premier jour j'avais un semaine qui a
suivi je n'ai rien deuxième semaine
générer un troisième semaine je n'ai
absolument aucun coup de fil
rappeler quand même à la fin du mois on
va aller prendre mon salaire je savais
le bureau que je devais occuper il
l'avait déjà arrangé et où le moi qui
avais avant donc je savais que si je
suis choisi je sais où je vais trouver
mon bureau là où je veux m'asseoir
qu'à la fin du mois je viens pour
prendre mon salaire et quand je rentre
dans le bureau il ya quelqu'un d'autre
là bas
quelqu'un assis là bas bah oui grosse
déception
très grosse déception
je continue dans mes boutiques donc je
commence à vadrouiller chaque jour du
fait des kilomètres avant des
dentifrices à vendre des produits
d'entretien
et un jour comme ça
on m'appelle on me dit écoute on sait
que tu étais passé mais beau x y z tu
n'as pas été choisie
challenge qui t'attend
on a besoin de quelqu'un qui fait la
même chose que ce pour quoi on peut
chercher
sauf que ça va être carabine et
de bois si toi on va t'expliquer
olg est palmolive eux maintenant
s'expatrient et où on a trouvé un
distributeur il est en guinée tu connais
la guinée
on a besoin de quelqu'un mais sauf que
là bas
pour apa le logiciel de lusine
fera pas les ingénieurs
fera rien du tout tu seras ce tout ce
qu'on te demande c'est de nous envoyer
chaque semaine les rapports de ventes ce
qui se fait dans la ville c'est à dire
que qu'est-ce qu'on a vendu la situation
du stock la situation des concurrents et
tout donc c'est ce que tu as à faire
bref on envoie au casse-pipe parce que
je connais mes compatriotes
quand on parle ils veulent aller aux
états-unis en france tout le monde rêve
d'aller s'expliquer et moi ça n'a jamais
été mon dada mais je ne sais pas j'avais
même pas de pièces d'identité quand on
m'a dit tu vas aller en guinée
ça m'a jamais intéressé 2 j'avais jamais
passé en fait que je vais voyager un
jour comme ça de manière aussi
ou d'un jeu vidéo
et donc là le 6 mai 2000 je me retrouve
dans un bureau maximum peut-être 12 12
14 mètres carrés chaque nom le patron de
l'export et puis les en train de
m'expliquer il est en train de me
convaincre que voilà je peux aller
trouver ma chance en guinée je peux
faire mes preuves là bas et que si tu
réussis labatut viendra ici tu pourrais
avoir un poste beaucoup plus élevé après
faut que je dise aux gens que mon nom en
fait ben jelloun ils sont pas collés
donc faut pas les coller c'est pas ben
jelloun sait pas donc déjà cédé épreuve
c'est tout le temps des épreuves même le
nom alors imaginez quand vous êtes dans
une cour de récréation et que vous devez
expliquer à vos camarades que moi et mon
petit frère bon on est de la même
famille lui les noirs moi je suis claire
il est saine moi je suis benjelloun mais
on sait mon frère après la question la
plus bête que j'ai toujours entendu
comment vous êtes frère en fait les gens
te pose la question
aux frères réfléchi si je te dis c'est
mon frère quand l'on doit à mon frère
c'est tout pas besoin que ce
que se donnent des preuves que c'est mon
frère est donc bref comme ça on est là
en train de me convaincre mais il faut
que j'aille en guinée et où donc comme
négocié quand j'ai négocié le salaire
alors moi les gars moi j'ai qu'une
ambition vous savez le salaire pour moi
c'est le salaire de moments et combien
elle a dit qu'elle a pas deux cent mille
donc pour moi deux cent mille c'est pour
moi la réussite pour moi j'ai des 100000
j'aime et 300 euros c'est la réussite
donc quand je me souhaite que le patron
me dis-je et envoie en guinée je te paye
ta maison l'appartement torah une
voiture sur un chauffeur je suis super
content et je te paye 300 milles
nous avons j'étais super content en tant
que bon négociateur vous savez vous
pouvez pas rigoler comme ça devant le
patron et vous dis un montant qui vous
dépasse voulu montrer que ça va pas quoi
en fait
avec un peu de recul on sait qu'il avait
déjà lu dans mon visage quand même que
j'étais déjà content avec les 3
et donc j'ai décidé de revenir j'ai dcid
comme ça que les trois 6300 1020 malin
mais il faudrait que je négocie encore
un peu plus
et là bas tu sais moi les dimanches
j'aime bien l'équipe du dimanche le foot
est allé final il ya du michael jordan
donc à la nba y'a pas tout ça et puis je
parle de ça je sais que chez moi on n'a
pas canal parce que canal c'était
réservé aux eaux privilégiées on se
retrouvait tous dans la maison d'un ami
on est à plus de 30 pour regarder la
télé quand vous rentrez faut faire pas
de pattes blanches à vous mettez un peu
de saleté vous revenez plus c'est fini
vous regardez plus de match de votre vie
et donc il me dit mais non il n'y a pas
de problème
tu auras canal c'est moi quitter le pays
je dis tu me paies un canal
vie bon manga
amène l'avion on part demain en guinée
et le 7 mai 2000 j'ai jamais oublié on
prend vol air afrique et puis on descend
ici en guinée c'est ma première fois je
découvre la guinée j'arrive un soir sur
le vol d air afrique la première chose
qui me kim kim qui me frappe in pardon
seller bocal de groupe les plats de
mayonnaise là que je vois à travers la
route des dames et m une bougie à
travers surtout le long de l'autoroute
ont fait ça donc je vois des bordés
bocal
des bocages
donc on met une bouillie smet une bougie
et donc c'est la première chose qui me
frappe
contrée d'essence et une nouvelle j'ai
une nouvelle vie
ce que je dis pas ce que je suis mariée
très jeune j'étais déjà mariée j'ai un
enfant parce que moi j'ai tout fait très
vite je ne sais pas comment ça se passe
mais dans ma vie 23 ans j'étais déjà
avec une femme et un enfant et donc je
commence comme ça laventure laventure
excusez moi colgate palmolive ici à
travers la société a à z corporation à
madina
donc j'arrive moi j'étais très heureux
mais en réalité moi j'arrive dans un
monde d'adultes où il ya des problèmes
que je ne sais pas en fait je vais
traverser une nouvelle épreuve où je
suis juste une victime collatérale en
fait quand j'allais les propriétaires de
la société ils sont assez suspicieux bon
pourquoi pas le guen nous envoie
quelqu'un pour voir nos chiffres pour
taper dans l'ordinateur est aussi ça se
trouve c'est un espion dans quelques
temps ils vont nous virer ils vont
prendre quelqu'un d'autre donc c'est
pour ça il est venu donc j'arrive en
fait je ne suis même pas en terrain
conquis j'arrive en fait non seulement
et tout faire moi-même en plus de ça ces
gens là ils me prennent pas pour un
allié donc imaginez
l'ordinateur le plus jamais eu dans ma
vie mais jamais jusqu'à présent je me
rappelle je dîne quand je vois les
jeunes d'aujourd'hui qui se plaignent de
tout oui d'où tout doux tout doux tout
doux tout moi je suis arrivé j'ai 23 ans
j'ai un bureau j'ai un ordinateur la
première des choses que je me demande
est ce que je mérite ça
est-ce que mouawad benjelloun
ou la peine qu'on m'achète un billet
d'avion
comme maître dans un appartement me
donne une voiture en me donnant bureau
c'est bêta mais c'est la question que je
me pose est ce que je méritais tout ça
donc mon savoir faire je peux le mot
n'est pour avoir ça je vous dis même pas
pour installer windows je vous dis à
l'époque à
ce soir et vous avez dû fréquenter vous
savez qu'à l'époque nos 10 q la
lé petit disque est là qu il faut 1 44
passes méga octet beaucoup de jeunes
n'ont pas connu ça
et dû aller chercher sur internet et à
l'époque l'internet c'était sur un seul
post sur le post du dg donc il va
falloir que tu es beaucoup de courage
pour aller lui dire excusez moi j'ai
besoin de faire quelque chose sur
internet mon île nous accordait que les
samedis les samedis j'avais le droit
avec les autres expats mais j'ai droit à
15 minutes pour rentrer voir ma mère à
mes mails rapidement vidé tout ce qui a
à voir et puis basta et donc je vais
aller faire pour moi une centaine
d'aller-retour pour aller juste découper
grâce grâce à zip
vais faire sans quelques méga les coupés
pour les mettre dans un disque pour
pouvoir installer ma machine pour que je
sois capable de donner le meilleur de
moi même et je les fais ça me plaît et
je continue comme ça mon travail
je devais continuer jusqu'au jour où
patatras les distributeurs et colgate ne
s'entendait plus on me dit c'est bon
maintenant écoute le contrat est fini il
faudrait que tu rentres et tout donc on
est en 2003 en mars 2003 j'ai dit ok y'a
pas de problème merci la guinée j'ai
bien travaillé j'ai fait mes trois ans
et tout jeu souvent tout se vend tout
dans l'appartement mais tout tout tout
tout tout tout tout tout
entre lui et moi je savais déjà que ça
va être très difficile parce que les
voir ne sont pas les mêmes quand tu m'as
pris l'ensemble maghrébin par enfant
dort il m'a mangé par contre s'ils
veulent et il me dit il me restait là
notre personnel et cazaux m'asseoir
posséder un toit léger comme directeur
général adjoint des douanes
quoi
la note générale était servi des
collections déjà
des conseils foutez de moi mon agenda
vous me disait des choses pas et donc
donc quelque part dans laquelle vous du
doigt mais je peux quand même de régler
avec
eno on discute il m'avait pas 6000 $
bien sûr on va y aller on va dire
montant qui n'est pas moche mais qui
fait un peu près 35 à 120 euros -5
31% du mobile et là je rentre à la
maison
j'ouvre la porte devant la chambre vous
connaissez les systèmes en fait
voilà on me dit quoi encore d'évidence
est loin d'avoir
maintenant un an il a pris suis exclue
j'ai mis des buts de notre mari ils
pensaient la même chose et que l'idée
n'est pas sûr qu'ils vont s'imposer ou
la danse et magie
de l'estival une cape et thoune malick
est un budget de s'évacuer vers le grand
prix de la pièce a conclu jean weinling
jeunes adolescents mais bien d'en parler
avec la et puis un problème c'est plus
d'oiseaux madame les enfants et tout et
tout ça grâce
au monde derrière le bureau est ce que
j'aime avec 12 ans aujourd'hui j'ai des
sociétés qui se bat pour histoire de
marteau et l'enclume et j'en étais hyper
fier mais je
râle toujours toujours toujours quand tu
étais là en galère pour ajouter à manger
six mois n'a pas de travail
tu l'arrivée du navire ces gens là vont
abandonner versa et c'est grâce à nos
gens
un nouveau visage ça sera
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]